great things happen at intersections in
fact I would argue that some of the most
interesting things of the human
experience occur at the intersections in
the liminal space whereby liminal I mean
the space in between there's freedom in
that in between freedom to create from
the indefiniteness of not quite here not
quite there a new self definition some
of the great intersections of the world
come to mind like the Arc de Triomphe in
Paris or Times Square in New York City
both bustling with the excitement of a
seemingly endless stream of people other
intersections like the Edmund Pettus
Bridge in Selma Alabama or Canfield
Drive and Copper Creek Court in Ferguson
Missouri also come to mind because of
the tremendous energy at the
intersection of human beings ideologies
and the ongoing struggle for justice
beyond the physical landscape of our
planet some of the most famous celestial
images are of intersections stars are
born at the messy intersection of gas
and dust instigated by gravity's
irrevocable pull stars die by this same
intersection this time flung outward in
a violent collision of smaller atoms
intersecting and efficiently fusing into
an altogether new and heavier things we
can all think of intersections that have
special meaning to us to be
intersectional then is to occupy a
position at an intersection I've lived
the entirety of my life in the in
between in the liminal space between
dreams and reality race and gender
poverty and Plenty science and society I
am both black and a woman
like the birth of stars in the
heavenlies this robust combination of
knowing results in a shining example of
the explosive fusion of identities I am
also an astrophysicist
I study Blazers supermassive hyperactive
black holes that sit at the Centers of
massive galaxies and shoot out jets
nearby those black holes at speeds
approaching the speed of light
inter-process we are still trying to
completely understand I have dreamed of
becoming an astrophysicist since I was
12 years old I had no idea that at that
time according to dr. Jamie Alexander's
archive of african-american women in
physics only 18 black women in the
United States had ever earned a PhD and
a physics related discipline and that
the first black woman to graduate with a
PhD in an astronomy related field did so
just one year before my birth as I
journeyed along my path I encountered
the best and worst at life at an
intersection the tremendous opportunity
to self define the collision of
expectation and experience the
exhilaration of Victoria's breakthroughs
and sometimes the the explosive pain of
regeneration I began my college
experience just after my family had
fallen apart our financial situation
disintegrated just after my father's
departure from our lives this thrust my
mother my sister and I out of the
relative comfort of middle-class life
and into the almost constant struggle to
make ends meet thus I was one of roughly
60% of women of color who find finances
to be a major barrier to their
educational goals
thankfully Norfolk State University
provided me with full funding and I was
able to achieve my bachelor's in physics
after graduation and despite knowing
that I wanted a PhD in astrophysics I
fell through the cracks it was a poster
that saved my dream and some really
incredible people in program
the American Physical Society had this
beautiful poster encouraging students of
color to become physicists it was
striking to me because it featured a
young black girl probably around 12
years old looking studiously at some
physics equations I remember thinking I
was looking directly back at the little
girl who first dared to dream this dream
I immediately wrote to the society and
requested my personal copy of the poster
which to this day still hangs in my
office I described to them in the email
my educational path and my desire to
find myself again in pursuit of the PhD
they directed me to the fist Vanderbilt
University Bridge program itself an
intersection of the masters and PhD
degrees at two institutions after two
years out of school they accepted me
into the program and I find myself again
on the path to the PhD after receiving
my masters at Fisk I went on to Yale to
complete my PhD
once I was physically occupying the
space that would ultimately give way to
my childhood aspirations I anticipated a
smooth glide to the PhD it became
immediately apparent that not everyone
was thrilled to have that degree of
liminality in their space I was
ostracized by many of my classmates one
of whom went so far as to invite me to
do what I really came here to do as he
pushed all the dirty dishes from our
meal in front of me to clean up I wish
that were an isolated occurrence but for
many women of color in science
technology engineering and mathematics
or stem this is something they have long
endured 100 percent of the 60 women of
color interviewed in a recent study by
Jonesy Williams at UC Hastings reported
facing racialized gender bias including
being mistaken for the janitorial staff
this mistaken identity was not reported
by any of the
women interviewed for this study which
comprised 557 women in total well there
is nothing inherently wrong with the
janitorial position and in fact my
forefathers and foremothers were able to
attend college because many of their
parents work these jobs it was a clear
attempt to put me in my place well there
was certainly the acute pain of the
encounter the real issue is that my
appearance can tell anyone anything
about my ability beyond that though it
underscores that the experiences of
women of color and stem do not
experience the same set of barriers that
just women or just people of color face
that's why today I want to highlight
women of color in stem who are
inexorably unapologetically living as
the inseparable sum of identities stem
itself is an intersectional term such
that it's true richness cannot be
appreciated without considering the
liminal space between disciplines
science the pursuit of understanding the
physical world by way of chemistry
physics biology cannot be accomplished
in the absence of mathematics
engineering requires the application of
basic science and math to the lived
experience technology sits firmly on the
foundation of math engineering and
science math itself serves the critical
role of rosetta stone decoding and
encoding the physical principles of the
world stem is utterly incomplete without
each individual piece this is to say
nothing of the enrichment that is
realized when stem is combined with
other disciplines the purpose for this
talk is twofold first to say directly to
every black latina indigenous first
nation or any other woman or girl who
finds herself resting at the blessed
intersection of race and gender that you
can be anything you want to be my
personal hope is that you'll become an
astrophysicist
but beyond that anything you want do not
think for one minute that because you
are who you are you cannot be who you
imagine yourself to be hold fast to
those dreams and let them carry you into
a world you can't even imagine secondly
among the most pressing issues of our
time most now find their intersection
with stem we have as a global society
solve most of the single faceted issues
of our time those that remain require a
thorough investigation of the liminal
space between disciplines to create the
multi-faceted solutions of tomorrow who
better to solve these liminal problems
than those who have faced their whole
lives at the intersections we as thought
leaders and decision makers must push
past the first steps of diversity and
into the richer and more robust
territory of full inclusion and equal
opportunity one of my favorite examples
of liminal excellence comes from the
late dr. Claudia Alexander a black one
of plasma physicist who passed away this
past July after a 10-year bout with
breast cancer she was a nasa project
scientist who spearheaded the nasa side
of the rosetta mission which became
famous this year for landing a rover on
a comet and the one and a half billion
dollar Galileo mission to Jupiter two
high-profile scientific victories for
NASA United States and the world dr.
Alexander said it this way I'm used to
walking between two cultures for me it's
among the purposes of my life to take us
from states of ignorance to states of
understanding with bold exploration that
you can't do every day
this shows exactly the power of a
liminal person she had the technical
ability to spearhead some of the most
ambitious space missions of our time and
she perfectly understood her place as
being exactly who she was in any place
she was Jessica
Matthews inventor of the socket line of
sports products like soccer balls that
generate renewable energy as you play
with them set it this way a major part
of invention isn't just creating things
it's understanding people and
understanding the systems that make this
world the reason I tell my story and the
story of dr. Alexander and Jessica
Matthews is because they are
fundamentally intersectional stories the
stories of lives lived at the Nexus of
race gender and innovation
despite implicit and explicit questions
of my right to be in an elite space I'm
proud to report that when I graduated I
was the first black woman to earn a PhD
in astrophysics in Yale's then three
hundred and twelve year history
I am now part of a small but growing
cadre of women of color and stem who are
poised to bring new perspectives and new
ideas to light on the most pressing
issues of our time things like
educational and equities police
brutality hiv/aids climate change
genetic editing artificial intelligence
and Mars exploration this is to say
nothing of the things we haven't even
thought of yet women of color and stem
occupy some of the toughest and most
exciting socio technological issues of
our time thus we are uniquely positioned
to contribute to and drive these
conversations in ways that are more
inclusive of a wider variety of lived
experience this outlook can be expanded
to the many intersectional people whose
experiences
positive and negative enrich the
conversations in ways that outmatch even
the best resource homogeneous groups
this is not a request born out of a
desire to fit in it's a reminder that we
cannot get to the best possible outcomes
for the totality of humanity without
precisely this collaboration this
bringing together of the Livan all the
differently lived distinctly experienced
and desperately impacted
simply put we cannot be the most
excellent expression of our collective
genius without the full measure of
humanity brought to bear thank